Oh Clem tectonic priority dollars other
important item of the program was
representation Pike lariam by commas are
commissioned Hagen you slow over me this
and active measures 360 million euro
will be used for short-term solution
market situation money would go to
member states visual a song i asked the
ministers of agriculture and ministers
of international trade to cooperate so
that agriculture is sufficiently
presented in negotiations this package
provides afford a robust robust response
to the market difficulties particularly
in the dairy sector and it means that
the European Commission has mobilized
more than 1.5 billion euro and new money
to support hard-pressed farmers in the
past two years there are seven actions
included in the in the package number
wonders of 150 million euros scheme to
support a voluntary reduction of EU milk
deliveries this scheme and operated EU
level so that farmers across the union
have access to it under the same
conditions secondly there is a 350
million euro adjustment aid targeted aid
package which will be implemented by
measures at member state level thirdly
member states are also given the
possibility to review their voluntary
couple support payments for tlie the
public intervention force cumin powder
is to be extended from the end of sep
tember to februari 2017 when the
standard period resumes and the seedings
up to which skim milk powder is born in
at fixed prices stays at 350 thousand
tons on till the end of december next we
are providing approval to member states
and paying agencies to advance payments
are up to seventy percent for direct
payments from the 16th of october and
before that if they wish to do so for up
to eighty-five percent for the area
based rural development payments and
finally we will bring forward an update
for withdrawal prices made by producer
organizations in the fruit and vegetable
sector
we also discuss simplification of
greening international trade as well as
the recent conference and unfair trading
practices in the food chain held by the
Slovak presidency in the first of July
with a discussion on the possible aid
for fires in Cyprus as well as the use
of phosphonates and organics